okay everyone looking good feeling good
how are we doing at the Golden Globe
we're doing fantastic just so happy to
be here yeah it's amazing it's
unbelievable
I didn't realize how bright it was
during all this it's like it is the day
it's it's the day and it's the day by
the way you said you're gonna wear suits
all awards season right and here we are
yeah baby now yeah busting a tackle
Kenzo suit I know the names stuff no
it's it's amazing and how amazing did it
feel even just the ride over here to
think that you guys are heading here
nominated what was kind of going through
your mind
oh just everything I mean this is just a
wonderful night and such like a magical
event so I'm just trying to savor every
moment it's amazing I mean she earned
the whole thing but it felt fake I'm
like they're gonna drop us off at
bubblegum shrimp and then we're gonna
yeah it's gonna be a big prank but we've
made it and so far they haven't pulled
us off so yeah we talked about the
fellow actresses in your category like
how do you feel to be in that company oh
I'm like no words I have no words I've
seen every movie in the category and I'm
just I don't know shops but like good
good shot well here's the thing you're
starting off strong girl okay I mean
here you are at the Golden Globes for
this movie does it make you think about
where you want to go from here have you
kind of thought wow Here I am and where
do I see myself in ten years even yeah a
little bit I mean I just I want to keep
doing what I enjoy and right now that's
acting so I'd like to keep doing it well
this is a good place to meet people to
network a little bit anybody you want to
work with who you're gonna say hello
tonight oh my god I mean Lady Gaga I
would still enjoy this yeah and also I
think if you win in this category you'd
be the youngest winner ever
isn't that crazy that would be cool
that's a cool thought LC fish are young
Golden Globe nominee winner effortless
you can tell I was perfect to play a
stuttering teenager
how much has your life changed though in
the past couple months when you think
about the way the movie has been
received
and adored and who you are at the Golden
Globes yeah it's insane I would not have
pictured myself here in a million years
but here we are ya know my life is
completely changed them Oscars next
we'll see we'll see watch well we'll be
on the couch together watching would
like some Jiffy Pop either way I'm chill
either way it's good and tell me one
secret about your outfit tonight
anything that it took to get into this
fabulous suit we had to fly it from
Paris
we pulled it and I had to be kind of
like custom-made so yeah by the way if
you're excited to meet Lady gaga are you
a star is born super fan like how much
did you love them I loved it so much I
was crying the entire time and she's
incredible and I mean Bradley Cooper to
sheeps those rosy red cheeks I'm Brad
Kupiec sunburned face whoo they made him
look weathered in a good way
where they're like burlap he looked like
a sexy pile of burlap all right would
you be at all interested in singing a
line from shallow I got a lot well it's
in the shallow level at Lowe's that's
the best come on give it to it I'm of
the deep and I can't that's like that's
her thing I gotta let her have it you
know enjoy your night snake
[Music]